scale of one to ten how good has my
appearance been today based on other
appearances i always think you're funny
you were awesome today yeah i always
love you on soap i think today very high
cause
funny
got old stories yeah which is always
good topical topical and i like serious
bird too i like we got into serious bird
where we got emotional conversational
burden
then we got into like okay after the
break burt you know the the alcohol's
starting to set in we're talking about
it definitely started selling all the
guys that bert wants to have sex with
himself and wants his wife to have sex
yeah those are the ones i regret i
remember one time yeah those when i when
i started being too honest a little bit
one more shot right same thing you still
never drank i've never drank no i've
never had it but i mean it looks fun
from here
it's the greatest thing in the world it
is
you got kids jim if you get if you get
diagnosed with cancer right would you go
on a [ __ ] terror
no yeah six months left not with
drinking i'd probably smoke pot because
you're drinking i didn't like how it
made me feel right here jim
we could do it right now no but i won't
do now but i mean if i have if i was
diagnosed with like stage four
pancreatic i knew i was gonna die
terrible influence maybe pot but that
liquor would make me nauseous and sick
and i just i didn't like how i was when
i drank but pot was one that i didn't
have any bad memories with you know how
do you realize your influence on
stand-up comedy sometimes about the
honesty stuff
i've no i honestly i feel like there's
zero but i appreciate it i i i 100 think
that
because i'm way too honest obviously i'm
this is ponying up on uh that i just
said i just i just i'll say whatever the
[ __ ] i believe yes because i stand by it
i thought it i feel it i that's
okay you want to hate me for it i get it
but that's who i am yeah you're like nas
and p diddy but you're the first guy
that like really kind of started that
for real the monster rain thing
was like the first thing where you were
like oh so we can tell our secrets and
they they make it ok it's okay and i i i
i wonder sometimes if you ever think
about that no i mean i appreciate it but
i think that's true i mean a lot a lot
of comedians after you have even come in
here and said like yeah that what an
influence
you and your style and those specials
were even before monster rain too some
of the stuff like the stuff you're doing
on the radio where it was like you were
who was talking about drinking piss
publicly rogan actually drank piss
rogan drank piss too are you serious
good for him
[Laughter]
yeah here we go
i'm about to drink my own pee on the
radio with no name
oh for a little while
yeah he drank because that was that was
a health cure back in the day i'm sure a
lot of people do that you know yeah and
rogan was like you know all about that
oh weak ass [ __ ] at youtube removed
my piss drinking video wow that's
13 years ago yeah yeah probably wouldn't
have come back up recently
um oh there it is yeah
drinking this piss yeah that's not i
mean that's oh that's him cleaning his
nose did you ever drink your own piss
i've probably tasted it in some way or
another yeah
i want to see you drink yours first
rogan is a beast yeah he is a beast yeah
no i've never drank my own wouldn't do
anything for me i mean i wouldn't freak
me out but dude you want to sell tickets
drink some piss now yeah you drink a lot
of other people's piss i have in many
pieces yeah
many of us it's so funny i have a joke i
have a joke that i've been telling out
of a cup straight from the tap
out of my hands out of my hands like i
was in the park after a basketball game
wasn't that like what first like got you
on uh o a that dice was telling a story
about you drinking it out of a champagne
glass oh yeah yeah yeah dice made me
tell the piss story mike called into
opie anthony yeah really yeah yeah he's
like tell him because he couldn't
believe it
that's like that's like you and will
will going bert tell him your story dice
takes jim into o and he goes jim tell
him your story
yeah well this is a story all about how
i drank my piss not from a cow
that worked yeah i'm a freestyler you
sure are yeah well listen guys are we
done we're done we love bird [ __ ] i know
we could do this all i could just hold
on one more shot and one more secret
okay okay one more secret go for a shot
shot first and then first and then
because i'm not i thought i was pacing
myself yeah and now i don't need to
anymore you don't need to day's over all
i gotta do is [ __ ] go back to my hotel
room sleep i have a conference call
three oh please today is my easiest day
i've ever had congratulations yes you
remember when we
saw a planet of the apes yes and i came
on and started [ __ ] on the movie
after it and you hit me up you're like
hey man
we're not allowed to talk about it yeah
yeah it was like uh what's it called
like uh a screen embargoed embargoed
yeah yeah because that wasn't even like
it wasn't for you like it was just like
it's like me and roland
it's so bad it doesn't even track it's
like one time
and
you enroll like hey man we're not
allowed to talk about the movie i was
like i'm on run bennington [ __ ] on
it
take it take a shot take a shot ask me a
question ask me a question
i'll take a shot ask me a question 100
truth okay okay what kind of question
travis are you curious about anything i
mean you've been a pretty open book and
this because of jim who's the person you
had the unpleasant interaction with on
that show
we won't ask any follow-ups i can't no i
can't i can't okay i can't because it
would [ __ ] them up oh okay i [ __ ] the
crew up oh [ __ ] i respect you for
announcing that before you took the shot
yeah i'm glad you asked me now you took
a shot yeah
okay i can't i can't it would it's not
fair all right fair enough they were
they were they didn't they didn't mean
to do it okay they were it was you know
look
rage's rage
oh there was rage
so you just gotta let it [ __ ] be and
i'm sure i'm sure i'm guilty of the same
[ __ ] thing and you're just unaware of
it you know like like when you go
i was a great guy in high school and
then someone's like you're a [ __ ]
bully and you're like what are you
talking about fat back and they're like
so
um
let's see
it should be a big hypothetical please
if you could like
we know if you could have sex with any
man it would be brad right that's your
guy
who's the lady
oh
that you would oh
even if your wife told you
bert i don't want you doing this you
would do it anyway the two most
beautiful women i've ever seen in person
are rosario dawson
and gwen stefani i have i say jennifer
nettles i think general is gorgeous
but we work together yeah rosario dawson
without a doubt is one of the most
strikingly beautiful women i've ever
seen
it without a doubt where you it catches
you off guard
um and you work with her on uh go back
to the show yeah she walked into a room
one time and i and she was in a [ __ ]
jumpsuit
and uh and i forgot we were on the same
show together and i said as she walked
in i went because of who's i just went
holy [ __ ]
that's how hot for zarya
gorgeous brilliant i love rosario um
gwen stefani is
i mean
gorgeous adjacent right
like
but if you're saying bert
who's who do i want to have sex with
yeah and that your wife would be like
bird if you do this i'm not gonna be
around anymore and you're like no i'm
gonna i gotta do it i'm doing this
without a doubt yeah
hey charlize theron
100
wow that's well worth it yeah that's so
worth it it's worth i know you got to
remember i'm throwing away my career
because my career is based on [ __ ] me
loving my wife and family right if you
just like yeah if i cheat on her i am a
phony i'm a fake i've never the whole
audience is like this isn't the journey
right right now i'm cool with that
for sure
yeah yeah and but i also need to know i
kind of want to know her net worth
because i need like we're going to lean
on her money you know
right because i'm not making any money
more money after this i can do your show
but i'm not selling tickets right
everyone's like oh yeah tell us about
[ __ ] charlie's thereon maybe maybe
they've been realized that'd be good for
one tour yeah one tour i was like yeah
uh charlize theron is so beautiful i
watched the fast and furious 20 or
whatever it was yeah when she's the
russian in a plane
yeah
the movie's [ __ ] laughable
right you mean when they have to stop
the missile from launching within a
fiera and they have sweat suits on it's
the best i was more attracted to her as
eileen warmus oh my god do you like her
i liked her attitude
and that was a close to jennifer aniston
because i think jenna anderson might be
one of the most perfect people
right do you mean jennifer anderson no
you uh she texted me one time by mistake
no yeah whoa me and tom that was how are
you worried that if you had sex with
jennifer aniston it would blow your shot
with brad pitt
let me tell you something for real if
brad pitt tried to kiss me i'd let him
i'm not even joking that's not a joke i
understand if he's like
okay name it can you name a celebrity or
if they lean in to kiss you you just
wouldn't you wouldn't push back much
like being slapped at the oscars you'd
just be like it happens right
laverne cox
brad pitt leans in for a kiss and that
kiss happens let me ask you this if brad
pitt leans in for a kiss
and you're kissing back do you think
you would contin like would you start to
make moves would you touch his hips yeah
like would you be would you be just a
person getting kissed or would you be
like the person going like no i think
we're gonna hook up
and motivating them so it starts it's
it's lip to lip first right and i'm sure
his tongue enters my mouth before before
i open it sure like his tongue opens the
door to my mouth like it slides through
my lips wait is this white this is sexy
this is sexy hold on it's okay to be
progressive yes i am i'm just so you're
brad you're wait can i not be super gay
right now no you can be i was just
thinking of the tongue pushing the lips
yes it's gonna because i'm gonna be
caught off guard it's much like a slap
at the oscars i don't know what's
happening you didn't know you're gonna
french brad pitt today i make a brad
pitt joke right and as opposed to him
hating it he loves it he walks on stage
and he comes up to me and my hands are
behind my back i'm holding onto the card
like chris rock and he goes in for the
kiss my lips will be closed that's how
they are on a kiss my first kiss ever
with marie koval in my bedroom my lips
were closed and her tongue opened my
lips and i
to this day yeah
so his tongue opened my lips so you want
to actually like you want your kiss with
brad pitt to be so special that it
mimics your first reality i want it to
be non-consensual
and i want to find consent inside the
kiss you want him to take the kiss yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah finally
consent inside the kiss yeah so sexy
yeah and it's what [ __ ] up everything
about what's going on in this world is
like sometimes a little non-consent
is sexy like a little bit of like i
didn't know i wanted this brad knowing
that you wanted a deep kiss brad knowing
i wanted a deep kiss and by the way i
hope brad hears this and and everyone
tag brad pitt in this clip please
i want him to know that when he meets me
for the first time i want this kiss yeah
so his tongue pierces my lips it opens
my mouth
i i'm confused i think that's the sexy
i'm confused
and
and then i match his energy
are you confused and you like if you're
shy
but the reaction of your body gives you
away
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so you take charge by grabbing the back
of his hair tell me about let's talk
about what we talked about the next
morning
we're in bed we're in bed right yeah and
we're talking about
we're in bed he's slept we're in bed and
he comes in with coffees and he was like
black and i went
you know it
did you watch hey big boy he goes yeah i
did
and he goes when he comes in with coffee
is he wearing a robe or is he still is
he naked
naked and he's got a hog on him and and
uh and he comes in he says crisscross
applesauce on the bed like maybe one
foot off the bed you know coffees
and he's like uh he's like hey man uh
do you like motorcycles and i go i love
motorcycles and he's like can you ride
and i went i actually had my license to
ride and he goes ah dude we should go to
my place i got these great motorcycles
so we wake up we have coffees right we
go to this house we got motorcycles we
ride through the hills together uh-huh
oh man it's a [ __ ] great day right do
you think you might like
because like you have daughters and
everything you might leave your family
i'm sorry they're they're out of my life
yeah they're driving like i can't
believe you brought them up in the
middle of this yeah you are a buzz
killer
[ __ ] kids right while i'm [ __ ]
bragging
hey georgia isla how's lacrosse practice
right that's done no [ __ ] them they're
[ __ ] go to college whatever i'm done
the old bert is gone yeah leanna collins
should be like what are you doing and i
was like i'm [ __ ] brad pitt click
good luck good luck baby good luck with
ron white would you would you be
uncomfortable
if there was an enema in the bathroom
and before you did it brad told you to
go in there and douche
uh it would make me uncomfortable
initially yep but i'd understand the
rules yeah i do shout yeah i mean it's
worth it it's worth it for what you're
about to experience
yeah i'd be i would be make me
uncomfortable at first but i'll be fine
with it i'll figure it out yeah wait am
i getting [ __ ] in the ass i thought
yeah i think we
no no no i don't think so really at
first she was spending the night well
how okay scenario we're in the scenario
how does brad pitt talk to me during sex
jim
lower the lights
perfect
is he nice is he sweet yeah he's he's
boy he's he's passionate he's more you
feel so good you're so soft
feels so nice nice big hairy nipples
that's what i like your taste taste and
he puts his fingers in your mouth
oh my dick's getting hard
and then what happens is
the next the next day
does he come inside me
we're not at that point yet this is the
first time for [ __ ] the next day
he's laying behind you and he's kissing
your neck and he slaps you on the ass
and he says uh
baby why don't you win the bathroom and
douche for daddy
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna honestly
i'm gonna go hey let's not do the daddy
thing
that's not what he wants to say that's
when he wants to do yeah he can't tell
brad pitt not to call not to call
himself daddy all right
all right good side i didn't mean to
wreck the vibe yeah
just a certain way turn me off yeah i
gotta let him know my boundaries fair
enough by the second night too yeah baby
why don't you go inside and douche it
gives you a little pat on the ass slash
[Laughter]
for benjamin buttons and then you go in
there and you [ __ ] douche out with an
enema yeah it's embarrassing no no hold
on it's not embarrassing hold on i'm
full into this because i also have to
lose some weight i'm dating brad pitt
yeah and enemas is a great way to lose
weight
i wouldn't be shocked if he got me onto
x-lacs and i started losing weight that
way because this is a life goal like we
are figuring ourselves out yeah does he
make me quit drinking
not at first but if you can't stay hard
when you're [ __ ] him
then you have to quit drinking
if you're losing your erections my
dick's rock hard don't worry about that
it's [ __ ] brad pitt
it's brad pitt and the day he brings
bradley [ __ ] cooper over to be like
we need to talk about your drinking i'm
like
you're not sexy to me anymore
what if he brings bradley cooper over
i'm not turn on my brother cooper oh
really no
never mind i won't ask then there's a
lot of like brad pitt represents here's
the reason a gay fantasy about brad pitt
works is he represents a lot to guys my
age
he is our movie star yeah like tom
cruise is a little younger he's done
doing things i watch brad prit brad pitt
kind of blossom and river runs through
it thumb and louise i watched his career
blow up and i and and he signed on to
him it's like benefit or uh or um or
matt damon that you
sign on to those guys
that's the thing with will smith yep you
sign on to those guys those are your
guys that's who you get that's your
movie star you get for your life and
he's maintained a coolness and he's
maintained coolness it's like trust me
when i say
for my dad it's de niro your dad would
have sex with robert de niro no but i'm
saying i bet you have a hard time not
saying no to a kiss